E aí
[Música]
bom E se eu te disser que eu não quero
sacrificar o meu trabalho em nome de uma
carreira você consegue ver sentido nessa
frase um sistema em que nós vivemos nos
dedicamos uma parte considerável do
nosso tempo e do nosso esforço ao que
nós convencionamos chamar de trabalho e
quando eu penso nesse termo trabalho a
definição que me vem à mente talvez não
seja mais convencional eu admito
adaptando o Nilton trabalho é uma
grandeza física relacionada a
transferência de energia devido à
atuação de uma força logo nós realizamos
um trabalho quando aplicamos uma força e
num corpo e este corpo sofre uma
transformação que geralmente é um
deslocamento
ao acessar esse conceito é fácil para
mim pois a física durante o todo o meu
ensino médio era minha matéria favorita
dividindo ali com a redação e desde cedo
eu gosto de aprender coisas que à
primeira vista pelo menos parecem
inconciliáveis como a combinação de
Mitologia e economia de história da arte
estatística e outras coisas que eu fui
lindo ao longo do tempo como resultado
eu sempre fui acusada de não ter foco
pelo menos nos Meus interesses Eu segui
assim por toda minha vida escolar me
interessando pelo que parecia ser
incompatível e na hora do vestibular eu
acabei optando pelas letras isso porque
muito cedo eu percebi que eu gostava de
trocar conhecimentos e visões de mundo
em Boas conversas e esse curso podia me
oferecer esse tipo de coisa seja por
meio da literatura da produção de texto
da linguística e todas as conexões que e
nos oferece esse mesmo interesse pelas
trocas e por temas habilidades e
assuntos que aparentemente não dialogam
entre si é algo que sempre me acompanhou
quando eu finalizei mestrado que fala
onde eu consegui Finalmente eu me as
pontas das letras e da física porque eu
fiz um mestrado na área de fonética
acústica Foi aí que eu percebi que eu
tava cansada da forma como funciona o
mundo acadêmico então Escolhi um seguir
o caminho que eu tinha traçado anos e
anos e anos atrás de emendar ou mestrado
doutorado e o pós-doutorado Eu comecei
no lugar disso a dar aulas em
pré-vestibulares uma escolha que me
marca até hoje eu estou professora de
redação linguagens e a qualidade há mais
ou menos uns 15 anos e aqui eu me
permito fazer uma pequena digressão
coisa típica de professores que
trabalham de forma tão íntima com a
linguagem
e enquanto o verbo ser designa as
características fixas de uma pessoa
descreve uma forma de existência o verbo
está que é o que eu prefiro geralmente
fala sobre o estado que pode e deve ser
temporário das coisas das pessoas ou de
uma situação assim quando eu Me
apresento em primeira pessoa eu prefiro
usar o verbo estar para os papéis
profissionais que ocupo afirmando uma
impermanência que é necessário essa
diferenciação é fruto de uma reflexão
que eu faço junto a outras vozes de
amigos autores e autoras eu trago sempre
comigo
algum tempo eu passei por uma séria
crise pessoal e profissional eu fui
diagnosticada com transtorno de
ansiedade generalizada e apresentava
alguns sinais Claros de síndrome de
bournout esse distúrbio é típico dos
nossos tempos e tá ligado de forma
profunda se convencionou chamar de
trabalho e foi aí que eu entendi que Eu
precisaria rever a minha relação com
algumas das minhas atividades e que eu
não sou o meu trabalho
bom hoje eu sei que os papéis que eu
assumo profissionalmente fazem sentido
no entanto ao meu ver eles não definem a
minha resistência na verdade eles
definem e delimitam uma ínfima parcela
dos Meus interesses que são diversos e
das minhas atividades
a pensar sobre isso e sobre essas
questões significa subverter os
significados e nós atribuímos ao
trabalho e com os quais nós estamos
habituados
bom e é por isso que eu retorno aqui a
definição retirada lá da física do
início da nossa conversa
o trabalho em termos laborais se
assemelha ao trabalho em termos físicos
pelo menos para mim é o fruto da
transferência de energia é um objeto é o
conjunto das forças que nós aplicamos
para provocar uma certa transformação e
isso extrapola a carreira salário
hierarquia e netas nós estamos falando
de usar a energia de que dispomos para
realizar uma mudança no ambiente que nos
cerca por isso eu quero dizer que o seu
trabalho não é o seu cargo
cargo é o conjunto de atividades a serem
desenvolvidas em uma instituição uma
empresa que você parar para pensar o seu
cargo é algo passageiro mas dentro de
uma mesma empresa por exemplo os cargos
ocupados variam de tempo em tempo que
faz mais sentido agora preferir um verbo
estar ao verbo ser quando nós falamos de
cargo ou de função que exercemos
concorda o seu trabalho muito menos é o
seu emprego que o ato de produzir algo
em troca de remuneração
e ele tem uma relação Direta com o nosso
estilo de vida projetos metas interesses
hobbies afetos trabalho é o conjunto dos
esforços que você faz fez e fará mesmo
que não intencionalmente que é o que eu
percebi nos últimos 36 anos de vida eu
te explico o que me diferencia no
mercado de trabalho hoje e eu proponho
desde já que a gente
repense essa expressão que os coloca
erroneamente como objetos disponíveis
para troca e venda é a capacidade de
circular entre diferentes o conhecimento
e quanto eu dou as minhas aulas
e o meu interesse por temáticas
aparentemente inconciliáveis foi tomado
como mera falta de foco Em alguns
momentos da minha vida mas o meu apreço
por coisas distintas não era nada mais
do que aquilo que eu era isso alguém
explorava explora interesses e Prazeres
e por isso eu fui ao longo do tempo me
esforçando para transferir energia para
as minhas paixões por mais incompatíveis
que elas parecessem ser entre Sim nesse
deslocamento de força provocou
transformações cujos resultados me
acompanham até hoje contrariando a minha
orientadora de Mestrado por exemplo que
me acusava de ser meio cabeça de vento
eu fiz matérias que supostamente não
contribuíram em nada para mim a formação
como história do cinema lógica acústica
bioestatística mas Se mostraram
eventualmente
imprescindíveis para que eu adquire-se
uma visão mais complexa da realidade e
das coisas que eu faço no dia a dia o
que alguns chamariam de falta de foco ou
cabeça de vento ou até mesmo de rebeldia
foi o que me trouxe até aqui a este
palco hoje eu vejo que tudo de no tio
ele incompatível que eu estudei que eu
vivi tudo aquilo que eu me entreguei foi
justamente o que me trouxe até este
instante
foram forças empregadas no sentido de
uma transformação a minha mas nada disso
foi intencional é tudo acaso e desejo é
fato que o conhecimento não deve ter uma
utilidade prática Eu acredito muito esse
utilitarismo contemporâneo Mas no fim no
seu próprio tempo o conhecimento é
sempre útil não necessariamente a sua
carreira hoje eu tenho oportunidade de
estar do outro lado em relação a quando
eu tava lá na escola ficou uma aluna tô
lá enquanto professora meu contato
diário com os meus alunos que estão
escolhendo a vida as portas do
vestibular e força sempre a traçar para
mim e para eles a linha entre trabalho e
carreira Pois todos eles relatam a
sensação de estarem perdidos e que não
há espaço para um suposto erro na hora
dessa escolha
esse pensamento extrapola a minha
relação com os meus alunos eu penso que
essas são as constantes que devem enviar
a nossa escolha de vida ou as nossas
escolhas de vida nossa então não falei
escolha de carreira e afinal em tempo de
mercado 4.0 como nós vamos nos preparar
para algo que está por vir mas que ainda
eu nem sei o que é estamos falando de
jovens e nem tão jovens assim cuja
profissão pode nem ao menos existir
ainda o que é possível portanto é que
nos preparemos para nossa jornada para
trilha que nós queremos traçar na nossa
vida e não apenas para uma carreira
determinada e que a gente não sabe nem
se vai dar certo inclusive pesquisas
recentes sobre esse mercado apontam que
enquanto a maioria dos empregos serão
automatizados porque são marcados por
ações repetitivas e rotineiras a busca
dos empregadores será por pessoas que
tenham habilidades como a capacidade de
aprender e de se adaptar além da
capacidade de tomar boas decisões e
principalmente trabalhar coletivamente
o E essas são as habilidades mais
difíceis de serem automatizadas eu digo
isso porque hoje as escolhas
supostamente aleatórias no meu passado
com me não na pessoa que eu sou fruto de
todas as forças Que eu apliquei e que me
deslocaram até este local do qual eu
falo para vocês
professora de pré vestibulares militante
feminista
empreendedora esposa amiga E agora mãe
só anteriormente eu disse que durante
toda minha vida eu me encantei pelo
supostamente inconciliável eu me atirei
contra os paradigmas
Agora eu quero fazer isso novamente e te
dizer você não é a sua profissão ou seu
emprego mas sim o seu trabalho no
sentido físico na coisa o emprego da
força o deslocamento de energia EA
mudança você é o objeto deslocado por
essas forças todas que andou aplicando
ao longo da sua vida
se você é você o conjunto dos seus
gostos das suas escolhas dos seus
interesses das suas preferências e Na
minha opinião não deveria sacrificar
todo esse trabalho em nome de uma mera
carreira e
E aí